The news surrounding COVID-19 is pretty depressing. The stock markets are tanking, the price of oil collapsed. The Centers for Disease Control and Prevention is warning that there could be a second more devastating round of infections ahead. Are you feeling anxious yet? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that looks at the connections between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills.
围绕新冠疫情的新闻令人相当沮丧。股市暴跌，油价崩盘。美国疾病控制与预防中心警告称，未来可能会出现第二波更具破坏性的感染。你感到焦虑了吗？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。
Now that we're well into our second month of sheltering in place, people are maybe losing motivation, finding it hard to exercise and eat right and get enough sleep. And if you have kids, how are they doing? Are they keeping up with their schoolwork, or are you too stressed to find out? Joining us today is Dr. Cion Bylock, a psychologist and president of Barnard College in New York. Dr. Bylock is one of the foremost researchers into embodied cognition, which looks at the connections between our minds and our bodies. She's also studied anxiety, especially math, anxiety, and girls and women. And she is one of the world's leading experts on the brain science behind choking under pressure and the many brain and body factors influencing all types of performance.
现在我们已经进入居家隔离的第二个月，人们可能正在失去动力，觉得难以锻炼、难以健康饮食和保证充足睡眠。如果你有孩子，他们的情况如何？他们能跟上学校的功课吗，还是你因为压力太大而无暇顾及？今天加入我们的是心理学家、纽约巴纳德学院院长希恩·拜洛克博士。拜洛克博士是具身认知领域最重要的研究人员之一，该领域研究的是我们的思想与身体之间的联系。她还研究过焦虑，尤其是数学焦虑，以及女性和女孩的焦虑。她是全球公认的顶尖专家，研究压力下“发挥失常”背后的脑科学，以及影响各种表现的诸多大脑和身体因素。
Welcome to speaking of psychology, Dr. Bylock. Thanks for having me. So in the interest of full disclosure, I have to say right up front that I graduated from Barnard with a degree in biology, but I will not tell you what year that was. That's fantastic. All right. That being said, I wanted to talk to you because of your varied and remarkable background and not because I went to Barnard. There are a lot of areas that we could talk about today.
欢迎来到《心理学谈话》，拜洛克博士。谢谢你的邀请。为了坦诚起见，我得先说明，我毕业于巴纳德学院，拥有生物学学位，但我不会告诉你那是哪一年。那太棒了。好了，话虽如此，我邀请你是因为你丰富而卓越的背景，而不是因为我曾就读于巴纳德。今天我们可以讨论很多领域。
So I expect our conversation will be a little bit free-ranging if that's okay. Perfect. But I hope that we can relate a lot of what we talk about to the COVID-19 pandemic because that's what is on everyone's mind right now. So at APA, we talk a lot about the mind-body connection, how our mental health is inextricably linked to our physical health. research shows the connections are real and that they're strong. You've done a lot of research in the area of embodied cognition as it's called. Could you explain that in more detail and how might it be relevant to our lives right now? Yeah, I think oftentimes we think of the mind and body connected in a one-way street, so to speak.
所以我预计我们的谈话会比较自由，如果可以的话。没问题。但我希望我们能把讨论的很多内容与新冠疫情联系起来，因为这是目前每个人都在关心的问题。在美国心理学会，我们经常谈论身心联系，即我们的心理健康与身体健康是如何密不可分的。研究表明，这种联系是真实且强大的。你在所谓的“具身认知”领域做了大量研究。你能更详细地解释一下吗？它与我们当下的生活有何关联？是的，我认为我们往往认为身心联系是单向的，可以这么说。
The mind sends signals to the body about how to act, what to do. But a lot of my research and the work behind embodied cognition suggests really that that that information flow runs both ways. So how you hold your body, whether you're sleeping enough, exercising has an impact on how you feel. And that's really important in this time, especially when many of us are indoors, not getting up as much, that we understand there is that strong connection and make it a priority in however way we can do it, whether it's inside or outside of social distancing, to get that body running because it helps us run our mind. So a lot of folks who are sheltering in place include children of all ages, many of whom are
大脑向身体发送关于如何行动、做什么的信号。但我的许多研究以及具身认知背后的工作表明，信息流实际上是双向的。因此，你的身体姿势、是否睡眠充足、是否锻炼，都会影响你的感受。在当前这个时期，这一点尤为重要，尤其是当我们许多人待在室内、活动减少时，我们必须理解这种强大的联系，并尽可能地将其作为优先事项，无论是在社交距离之内还是之外，都要让身体动起来，因为这有助于我们的大脑运作。所以，许多居家隔离的人包括各个年龄段的孩子，他们中有许多人
trying to keep up with their studies remotely. As an educator, do you have any advice for how parents can help their kids stay on top of their studies under these conditions? So I have some advice as a researcher and also as a mom to a nine-year-old who's doing, going through the same things. And I think, you know, the first thing to really remember as a parent is to give yourself a break, right? We can't hold ourselves. or our kids to the same standards we held ourselves outside the pandemic. And in many cases, it really doesn't matter. And the best example I like to give is with young kids.
正试图远程跟上学业。作为一名教育工作者，对于父母如何帮助孩子在这种情况下保持学业进度，你有什么建议吗？作为一名研究人员，同时也是一个正在经历同样事情的九岁孩子的母亲，我有一些建议。我认为，作为父母，首先要记住的是要让自己喘口气，对吧？我们不能用疫情之外的标准来要求自己或孩子。在许多情况下，这真的没那么重要。我喜欢给出的最好例子是关于幼儿的。
Oftentimes parents are really obsessed with when their kid learns to read and whether their kid is the first reader in the class or early in the group. And all the research suggests that when a kid learns to read has no impact on later academic functioning. And so it's those kinds of ideas which really are important for us to remember. in terms of giving ourselves a break. So, for example, it's much more important that your young child feels good about math and has the viewpoint that he or she can learn math,
通常父母非常纠结于孩子什么时候学会阅读，以及他们的孩子是否是班上第一个学会阅读的，或者是否属于较早的一批。但所有研究都表明，孩子何时学会阅读对以后的学术表现没有影响。因此，这些观念对于我们记住“让自己喘口气”非常重要。例如，让你的幼儿对数学感觉良好，并认为他或她能够学习数学，这要重要得多，
that it's something you acquire with practice, then knows every fact for his or her age group. Our attitudes are really important right now, and I think that's something we can all focus on and we can all have control over. So that alludes to the research you've done into the connections between parents, math, anxiety, and that of their kids, and also just the parent connection to children's academic and social development. You talk a little more about those factors and how they might be playing into the current scenario of parents and kids sheltering in place.
这是一种通过练习就能获得的技能，而不是要求他们掌握同龄人所知的每一个事实。我们的态度在当下非常重要，我认为这是我们所有人都可以关注并掌控的事情。这提到了你所做的关于父母、数学焦虑及其对孩子影响的研究，以及父母与孩子学业和社会发展之间的联系。你能多谈谈这些因素，以及它们在当前父母和孩子居家隔离的情况下是如何发挥作用的吗？
Yeah. So, first of all, it's just really important to remember that what parents do with their kids does matter. So I think oftentimes parents think that reading is something you might do at home. bedtime stories, for example. But math is the purview of school. I mean, you don't hear a lot of people doing bedtime math. That would be funny. And in fact, my research group has studied an app called bedtime math, which is free on iTunes and Android. And we've shown that when parents are able to engage with their kids in fun and interesting ways around math, their kids do better in school and math. And that's especially true for parents who are most anxious about math. So a lot of adults, especially in the U.S.
是的。首先，记住父母与孩子的互动确实很重要，这一点非常关键。我认为父母往往认为阅读是可以在家里做的事情，比如睡前故事。但数学是学校的范畴。我的意思是，你很少听到有人做“睡前数学”。那会很有趣。事实上，我的研究小组研究过一款名为“睡前数学”的应用程序，它在iTunes和安卓系统上都是免费的。我们已经证明，当父母能够以有趣和吸引人的方式与孩子一起参与数学活动时，他们的孩子在学校和数学方面的表现会更好。对于那些对数学最焦虑的父母来说，情况尤其如此。所以很多成年人，特别是在美国，
don't like math or afraid of math. You don't hear highly intelligent people walking around bragging that they're not readers, but you do hear them bragging that they're not good math people. And unfortunately, that does tend to seep in and affect our kids. And people who are anxious about math, parents tend to do less math with their kids. When they do help them with homework, they can disrupt it. And so really, right now, the most important thing,
不喜欢数学或害怕数学。你不会听到高智商的人到处吹嘘自己不爱阅读，但你确实会听到他们吹嘘自己不擅长数学。不幸的是，这种情绪往往会渗透并影响我们的孩子。对数学感到焦虑的父母往往会减少与孩子一起进行的数学活动。当他们帮助孩子做作业时，可能会产生干扰。所以现在，最重要的事情，
I would say, especially for parents who are anxious, is to help your kid have a good attitude about math. Saying things like, oh, it's okay, I don't like math either, or I'm not a math person. Might be trying to make them feel good, but it's sending a signal that either you've got the math gene or you don't. But instead saying, hey, this is difficult. Let's struggle through this together,
我想说，特别是对于那些焦虑的父母，是帮助你的孩子对数学保持良好的态度。说些诸如“哦，没关系，我也不喜欢数学”或“我不是学数学的料”之类的话，可能是在试图让他们感觉好受些，但这传递了一个信号，即你要么有数学基因，要么没有。相反，应该说：“嘿，这很难。让我们一起努力克服它，”
showing that it's okay to make progress, but maybe not get the right answer. All those things are things we can model now for our kids that are so important. Some of your research has looked at how to reduce the performance gap, between lower income and higher income students, particularly in the sciences. Do you think that lower income kids are in danger of falling further behind as a result of the current pandemic? Are there strategies that you might recommend for parents to help their kids stay focused
展示出取得进步是可以的，即使没有得到正确答案也没关系。所有这些都是我们现在可以为孩子树立的榜样，它们非常重要。你的一些研究着眼于如何缩小低收入和高收入学生之间的表现差距，特别是在科学领域。你认为低收入家庭的孩子是否面临因当前疫情而进一步落后的危险？你有什么策略建议父母帮助孩子保持专注
and not fall behind? I mean, I certainly think that when we're in a state like this, it oftentimes augments socioeconomic divides rather than shrinks them, unfortunately. And so it is really important to think about how we can support everyone. At Barnard, for example, we went to a mandatory pass, fail for all of our classes, for all of our students for the remainder of the semester when we went online. And the reason we did that is because we knew that we could somewhat control students living environments when they were on campus, but we couldn't when they went home.
而不掉队吗？我的意思是，我当然认为当我们处于这种状态时，不幸的是，它往往会加剧而不是缩小社会经济差距。因此，思考我们如何支持每个人确实非常重要。例如，在巴纳德学院，当我们转为线上教学时，我们对所有学生在剩余学期内的所有课程实行了强制性的“通过/不通过”评分制。我们这样做的原因是，我们知道当学生在校园时，我们可以控制他们的生活环境，但当他们回家后，我们就无法控制了。
And some kids were going to their parents' second home, and some kids were going home to a family where they were going to have to help support what was going on. And we really did this for inequality reason. We didn't want some students to suffer just because they didn't have the time or the means to be able to focus in the right way. And so this is something especially important to think about with parents and their kids as well. Many lower income families, their parents are essential workers and working on the front lines are, it's stressful, right? So anything that we can think of to help make these activities fun for our kids, to even ask them what they're doing in school to at least engage in conversations, I'd say anything right now goes a long way.
有些孩子回到了父母的第二个家，而有些孩子回到了需要他们帮忙维持生计的家庭。我们这样做确实是出于不平等的考虑。我们不希望有些学生仅仅因为没有时间或条件以正确的方式专注学习而受到影响。因此，在考虑父母和孩子的问题时，这一点也特别重要。许多低收入家庭的父母是必要工作人员，在第一线工作，这很有压力，对吧？所以，任何能让我们想到让这些活动对孩子来说变得有趣的方法，甚至只是问问他们在学校做什么，至少进行一些对话，我认为现在任何一点努力都会大有帮助。
So since much of your research has focused on how our physical surroundings shape, how we feel, think, and behave, how do you think sheltering in place might affect our minds and our bodies? Well, we know that, you know, a lack of movement, changing surroundings can affect our ability to be creative. So, for example, there's psychological research showing that when you get up and walk away from a problem, you're often likely to gain that aha moment. It's not necessarily when you're banging your head against the wall. And it's much easier to do that when you're in an office and you get up to go to the water cooler or when you commute to and from work. And so now I would say it's important for us to create those strategies, right? How can we set a schedule or we do have time to get away from our computer? At what time at night do we turn off our phone and computer?
既然你的许多研究都集中在我们的物理环境如何塑造我们的感受、思维和行为上，你认为居家隔离可能会如何影响我们的思想和身体？嗯，我们知道，缺乏运动、环境的变化会影响我们的创造力。例如，有心理学研究表明，当你起身离开问题时，你往往更有可能获得“顿悟”时刻。这不一定是在你撞墙的时候。当你身处办公室，起身去饮水机旁，或者上下班通勤时，这样做要容易得多。所以现在，我认为重要的是我们要制定这些策略，对吧？我们如何设定时间表，让我们有时间离开电脑？晚上几点关掉手机和电脑？
And how do we help create surroundings that can relax and infigrate and energize us? And in opposition to what we used to know is normal daily life, I think we have to do a little more work to create that now. So we know the COVID-19 pandemic is affecting higher education, just like it is other workplaces and institutions. I wanted to talk a little more about what's happening at Barnard, which is relatively small, about 2,400 students, right? Yeah. Also, maybe what's happening at the larger Columbia University world and beyond. What is happening to the students and the faculty right now? Well, Barnard is really special because it's a small institution-focused.
我们如何帮助创造能够放松、激发活力和赋予我们能量的环境？与我们过去认为的正常日常生活相比，我认为我们现在必须多做一点工作来创造这种环境。我们知道新冠疫情正在影响高等教育，就像它影响其他工作场所和机构一样。我想多谈谈巴纳德学院的情况，它相对较小，大约有2400名学生，对吧？是的。还有，哥伦比亚大学及其他地方正在发生什么？学生和教职员工现在怎么样了？嗯，巴纳德很特别，因为它是一个专注于
on empowering women. So you get this small, fantastic liberal arts education, but under the umbrella of the larger Columbia University. So I always talk about it as the best of all worlds. And we're linked in a lot of ways. So for example, many students at Columbia come over to Barnard to take classes every day and vice versa. And so there's so many ways that we're interconnected. And it's been really interesting to watch the whole university system and Barnard really make a quick move online. I mean, we did this in just a few weeks, and I've been so proud of our faculty and our students. I've been doing weekly coffee chats with about 10 of our students online each week, and they talk about the faculty and how important it is for them to have the classes and stay
赋权女性的小型机构。所以你得到的是这种小型、出色的文科教育，但处于哥伦比亚大学这个更大的保护伞下。所以我总是说它是两全其美的。我们在很多方面都是相连的。例如，许多哥伦比亚大学的学生每天都到巴纳德上课，反之亦然。所以我们以多种方式相互关联。看着整个大学系统和巴纳德迅速转向线上教学，这非常有趣。我的意思是，我们在短短几周内就完成了这一点，我为我们的教职员工和学生感到非常自豪。我每周都会与大约10名学生进行在线咖啡聊天，他们谈论教职员工，谈论拥有课程并保持
connected, because I think many of our students are isolated in ways they didn't expect. So do you feel like this is helping the students to have a full educational experience, even though they can't be on the campus? I do think that all of what we're doing online, we're doing a lot of community building. We are, our faculty are running extra seminars. They're teaching classes multiple times to make sure if students are in different time zones they can get to the class. I feel like all of that is helping a lot. And our students are telling us that it's really important to have those sorts of connections, especially in a time where they aren't getting them in other places. Are you talking to other college presidents about what their challenges are?
联系对他们来说有多重要，因为我认为我们的许多学生正以他们意想不到的方式被孤立。那么你觉得这是否有助于学生获得完整的教育体验，即使他们不能在校园里？我确实认为我们在线上所做的一切，正在进行大量的社区建设。我们的教职员工正在举办额外的研讨会。他们多次教授课程，以确保如果学生在不同的时区，他们也能参加课程。我觉得所有这些都有很大帮助。我们的学生告诉我们，拥有这种联系非常重要，特别是在他们无法在其他地方获得这些联系的时候。你是否在与其他大学校长交流他们的挑战？
Yes. I think higher education in general, we do a good job of learning and talking to each other. And we're learning and talking to each other both in New York City, State, and then I talk to my peers also as well. And what are they telling you? I mean, are you getting ideas from them? Are you sharing best practices? You know, it's a little of both. I think Barnard was ahead in many things in terms of of, as I said, our decision to go past, no pass in terms of our really, I would argue, clear communication with the students. And one thing that we did that was different than a lot of institutions is that we made the decision to allow students to stay on campus if they couldn't get into their home country or really were housing insecure. And I've gotten a lot of
是的。我认为高等教育界总体上在学习和相互交流方面做得很好。我们正在纽约市、州内进行学习和交流，我也与我的同行们进行了交流。他们告诉你什么？我的意思是，你从他们那里得到想法了吗？你们在分享最佳实践吗？你知道，两者都有。我认为巴纳德在很多方面都处于领先地位，正如我所说，我们决定实行“通过/不通过”评分制，以及我可以说我们与学生进行了非常清晰的沟通。我们做的一件与许多机构不同的事情是，我们决定允许那些无法回到自己国家或确实住房不稳定的学生留在校园。我收到了很多
feedback from our community about how much they appreciated that. It's a small number of students, but we really do feel like Barnard is a community, and it's not just a community for two semesters. It's a community throughout the years, and you as an alum, hopefully, feel that as well. And so we only, we have a very small number of students on campus, but I think it was so important to be able to continue to provide support for them. Wow, that's, that's amazing that you're able to do that. You say a small number about how many? We have about 150 students on campus, so out of our 2400 that usually are on campus. So almost all of them went home. Have the ones who were there, have they all moved into the same dorm? Are they separate? I mean,
来自我们社区的反馈，他们非常感谢这一点。学生人数很少，但我们确实觉得巴纳德是一个社区，它不仅仅是两个学期的社区。它是贯穿多年的社区，作为校友，希望你也有这种感觉。所以我们只有极少数学生在校园里，但我认为能够继续为他们提供支持非常重要。哇，你能做到这一点真是太了不起了。你说极少数，大约有多少？我们校园里大约有150名学生，而我们通常有2400名学生在校。所以几乎所有人都回家了。在那里的人，他们都搬进同一个宿舍了吗？他们是分开的吗？我的意思是，
how are you doing this? We did just recently have them co-locate to more apartment-style living close together while maintaining social distancing, of course, and own rooms. But we wanted to make sure that they had a community. I think that's really important. I mean, this is is not just physically isolating. It's mentally isolating. And this also allowed us to reduce the number of shifts that are essential workers that are still on campus needed to be there. So instead of coming in five days a week when we're able to help consolidate some of the students, some of our workers were able to come in two or three times a week. So what's happening to your admissions process right now? How are you handling that?
你们是怎么做的？我们最近确实让他们搬到了靠近彼此的公寓式住所，当然同时保持社交距离，并且拥有独立的房间。但我们想确保他们有一个社区。我认为这非常重要。我的意思是，这不仅仅是身体上的隔离。这是精神上的隔离。这也使我们能够减少仍然在校园里的必要工作人员的轮班次数。因此，当我们能够帮助整合一些学生时，一些工作人员就不必每周来五天，而是可以每周来两到三天。那么你们现在的招生过程怎么样了？你们是如何处理的？
We are, our deadlines May 1st. We're building a fantastic class of 2024. I think Barnard is in a fortunate position here. We had over 9,400 applications this year for around 600 spots. It makes us one of the most selective of any college or university in the country. And so we really have a fantastic and strong class coming in. I will say that for next year's class, current juniors, we are going test optional for one year to make sure that students aren't prohibited from applying because they weren't able to take an SAT or an ACT. Yeah, yeah, that's a big problem for some kids. So students at some universities are suing their schools over the COVID-19 shutdowns. Some students want refunds of tuition fees and other costs because they feel they're not getting the full benefit of an on-campus education. Of course, on the other hand, colleges and universities are losing a lot of money because of the shutdown. So what is happening at Barnard? And do you have any intelligence about what's happening across the street at Columbia?
我们的截止日期是5月1日。我们正在组建一支优秀的2024届学生队伍。我认为巴纳德在这方面处于有利地位。今年我们收到了超过9400份申请，录取名额约为600个。这使我们成为全国选择性最强的学院或大学之一。所以我们确实有一批非常出色和强大的新生即将入学。我要说的是，对于明年的班级，即现在的三年级学生，我们将实行一年的“标化可选”政策，以确保学生不会因为无法参加SAT或ACT考试而被禁止申请。是的，是的，这对一些孩子来说是个大问题。所以一些大学的学生正在就新冠疫情导致的停课起诉他们的学校。一些学生要求退还学费和其他费用，因为他们觉得没有享受到校园教育的全部好处。当然，另一方面，学院和大学因为停课损失了很多钱。那么巴纳德正在发生什么？你对街对面的哥伦比亚大学的情况有什么了解吗？
Well, I mean, I think we are working really hard to support our students. We did refund room and board for students who left prorated based on when they left. And they are getting the academic experience, so we feel comfortable with that. and we know how hard their faculty have worked to help mount those programs and really be a lifeline for a lot of students in this time. One thing that we've done at Barnard, and I think we're one of the first institutions to do this, is that we do have a lot of summer programs on campus where students take part. For example, we have the Summer Research Institute where we fund with a stipend over 200 students each summer to live on campus for 10 weeks and work in a lab. at Barnard, Columbia, or around the city. It's really an important part of being a science major at Barnard. We're a third of our graduates, our math and science majors. And we unfortunately had to
嗯，我的意思是，我认为我们正在非常努力地支持我们的学生。我们为离开的学生按比例退还了食宿费。他们正在获得学术体验，所以我们对此感到欣慰。我们知道他们的教职员工为帮助开展这些项目并在这个时期成为许多学生的生命线付出了多少努力。我们在巴纳德做的一件事，我认为我们是首批这样做的机构之一，就是我们确实有很多学生参与的校园暑期项目。例如，我们有暑期研究学院，我们每年夏天资助200多名学生，每人提供津贴，让他们在校园里生活10周并在实验室工作。在巴纳德、哥伦比亚大学或城市周围。这确实是巴纳德科学专业学生的重要组成部分。我们三分之一的毕业生是数学和科学专业的。不幸的是，我们不得不
postpone that program this summer. And we know that students are going to have problems with summer work. And at Barnard, we're need blind and we meet full financial need, but we do ask students to make a contribution based on their summer earnings. And so this year we announced that for all incoming and continuing sophomores, juniors, and seniors and all incoming first years, Barnard will pay their summer contribution. It's a significant expense for us, about $3 million, but we really felt it was important to support financial aid students in that way, because we knew that they were going to be strained in terms of being able to make that summer contribution. So what do you foresee in the world of higher education come this fall? Are you still prepared to continue distance learning or is it too soon for you to say much about this?
推迟了今年夏天的那个项目。我们知道学生在暑期工作方面会遇到问题。在巴纳德，我们实行“需求盲审”并满足全部经济需求，但我们确实要求学生根据他们的暑期收入做出贡献。因此，今年我们宣布，对于所有即将入学和在读的二年级、三年级、四年级学生以及所有即将入学的一年级新生，巴纳德将支付他们的暑期贡献金。这对我们来说是一笔巨大的开支，大约300万美元，但我们确实觉得以这种方式支持经济援助学生非常重要，因为我们知道他们在暑期贡献金方面会感到吃力。那么你对今年秋天高等教育界的前景有何预测？你们是否准备好继续远程学习，还是现在说这些还为时过早？
We expect to be back on campus, but of course it would be irresponsible to not do contingency planning. And I think it's really important to remember that it's not all or nothing. It's not all online or all in person. There's lots of creative things to think about in between. And I think it's actually a really exciting time for higher education in terms of understanding what is so valuable. about the residential experience, and it is valuable. Any of us who have older kids at home, we all know that most of the parents and most of the kids want to be back at school. Everyone's pushing in the same direction. I have two college students at home and a nine-year-old,
我们预计会回到校园，但当然，不做应急计划是不负责任的。我认为记住“并非非黑即白”非常重要。并非全是线上或全是线下。中间有很多创造性的想法可以考虑。我认为对于高等教育来说，这是一个非常令人兴奋的时期，可以理解什么是如此宝贵。关于住宿体验，它确实很有价值。我们任何家里有大孩子的人都知道，大多数父母和大多数孩子都想回到学校。每个人都在朝着同一个方向努力。我家里有两个大学生和一个九岁的孩子，
and neither the college students nor me want them here much longer. So, I mean, all kidding aside, I'm very happy they're home and safe. But I mean, I think it shows how valuable that residential experience is. That doesn't mean that we can't be so creative in all of this and learn some really interesting things. And I think, you know, this is really an important time to do that. So I have to ask for our members and our psychologist listeners who are tuned into the podcast. How does your being a psychologist affect your being president of a college? It's a really great question.
无论是大学生还是我，都不希望他们在这里待太久。所以，撇开玩笑不谈，我很高兴他们回家并且安全。但我的意思是，我认为这表明了住宿体验是多么宝贵。这并不意味着我们不能在这一切中发挥创造力并学到一些非常有趣的东西。而且我认为，你知道，这是一个非常重要的时期。所以我必须问问我们的会员和收听播客的心理学家们。你作为心理学家的身份如何影响你作为大学校长的身份？这是一个非常好的问题。
I mean, I think my psychology has always sort of seeped into the rest of. my life. You know, people ask me how I got interested in choking under pressure, performance under stress. And I say I've always done a little bit of knee search in addition to research. You know, I'm interested in how I perform. And now as being president of Barnard, I certainly bring tools of cognitive science to the table in terms of one place where it really is important to me is in terms of creating a senior leadership team where diverse opinions, diverse lived experiences, and a lot of back and forth really matter. I know the best decisions, for example, get made when people feel comfortable voicing contrary
我的意思是，我认为我的心理学背景一直渗透到我生活的其他方面。你知道，人们问我如何对压力下的发挥失常、压力下的表现产生兴趣。我说我除了研究之外，还做了一点点“自我研究”。你知道，我对自己的表现很感兴趣。现在作为巴纳德的校长，我当然把认知科学的工具带到了桌面上，其中一个对我来说非常重要的地方是建立一个高级领导团队，在这里，多元化的观点、多元化的生活经历以及大量的交流非常重要。我知道，例如，当人们感到可以自由表达与规范相反的意见时，最好的决策就会产生。
opinions to the norm. And so I work really hard as a leader to create that sort of environment. And I think that trickles down to the rest of campus. I think college and universities are a place where you need really different ideas and challenging ideas and people with very different perspectives to get together to get the best research done. And so I bring that with everything I do. But you pretty much had to walk away from the world of research, right? I mean, would you have any time now to continue the work that you had been doing? I'm actually doing it on a smaller scale. I mean, I've always split my time a bit. I have written two popular audience books while I've run my lab. When I was at Chicago for my last several years as a professor, I was also executive vice provost of the university. So I've always had a bit of a juggling act. And I found ways to really integrate it and meaningful ways. So for example, for our admitted students at Barnard, I gave a virtual Zoom class last week about some of my research and the science.
所以我作为领导者非常努力地创造那种环境。我认为这会渗透到校园的其他地方。我认为学院和大学是一个需要真正不同的想法、具有挑战性的想法以及具有非常不同视角的人们聚集在一起，才能完成最好研究的地方。所以我把我所做的一切都带到了这里。但你几乎不得不离开研究领域，对吧？我的意思是，你现在还有时间继续你一直在做的工作吗？我实际上是在较小的规模上进行。我的意思是，我一直都在分配我的时间。我在经营实验室的同时写了两本大众读物。当我在芝加哥担任教授的最后几年里，我还是大学的执行副教务长。所以我一直都在进行某种平衡。我找到了真正整合它和有意义的方法。例如，对于我们巴纳德的录取学生，我上周上了一堂虚拟Zoom课程，关于我的一些研究和科学。
behind performance under stress. And it was a fantastic way to tell them a little bit about some of the work that we're currently doing and get new students excited. So I think there's always opportunities to meld it together. And I am still running a small lab. And it's important for me. And I think it's important for a lot of leaders of institutions to have that sort of grounding in being a faculty member, being a scientist, if you are, it makes a difference in terms of how you lead. So you have any final words for the concerned students and parents who are listening to us today? I would just say that, you know, it's okay to be anxious in this time. Where we can really control things is giving ourselves a break. I talk a lot about how we're often the hardest on ourselves.
关于压力下的表现。这是一个向他们介绍我们目前正在进行的一些工作并让新生感到兴奋的绝佳方式。所以我认为总有机会将它们融合在一起。我仍然在经营一个小实验室。这对我来说很重要。而且我认为对于许多机构的领导者来说，拥有作为教职员工、作为科学家的那种基础很重要，如果你是的话，这会对你的领导方式产生影响。那么你对今天收听我们节目的担忧的学生和家长有什么最后的寄语吗？我只想说，你知道，在这个时期感到焦虑是可以的。我们真正能控制的事情是让自己喘口气。我经常谈论我们是如何对自己最苛刻的。
So the example I like to give is that sometimes the way you talk to yourself, you'd never talk that way to a friend. You're often much harder on yourself in terms of how you're feeling, how you're performing, what you're accomplishing, what you're not. And I think this is really a time more than ever for us to relax a little bit and relax our expectations for ourselves. We know that we are being in uncertainty can cause the most anxiety. And so knowing that and then giving yourself a little bit of permission to be anxious and not sort of holding your feet to the fire is okay right now. And so we will tackle this. Like we've tackled other challenges. situations in our past. And I think right now you control what you can and you have to give yourself
所以我喜欢给出的例子是，有时你对自己说话的方式，你永远不会那样对朋友说话。在你的感受、表现、成就以及未完成的事情方面，你往往对自己要求更严。我认为现在比以往任何时候都更需要我们放松一点，放宽对自己的期望。我们知道，处于不确定性中会引起最大的焦虑。所以知道这一点，然后给自己一点许可去焦虑，而不是那种逼迫自己，这在现在是可以的。所以我们会解决这个问题。就像我们过去解决其他挑战性情况一样。我认为现在你控制你能控制的，你必须对自己无法控制的事情
a break with what you can't. Good advice. Thank you. Thank you for joining us today, Dr. Bylock. It was a privilege to talk to you. Happy to be here and I love hearing from Barner, grad. Well, I wish you and Barnard the best going forward, of course. And to you, our listeners, thank you for tuning in. This is part of a series of podcasts APA has produced regarding psychology's role in helping us understand and navigate the COVID-19 pandemic. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on Apple, Stitcher, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. You can also go to our website and listen to all episodes at www.combeatingof Psychology.org. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, email us at speakingof psychology at APA.org. Thank you for listening for the American Psychological
宽容一点。很好的建议。谢谢。谢谢你今天加入我们，拜洛克博士。能和你交谈是我的荣幸。很高兴来到这里，我喜欢听到巴纳德毕业生的消息。好吧，我祝愿你和巴纳德未来一切顺利。当然。对于你们，我们的听众，感谢收听。这是美国心理学会制作的一系列关于心理学在帮助我们理解和应对新冠疫情方面所起作用的播客的一部分。你可以在Apple、Stitcher、YouTube或任何你获取播客的地方找到《心理学谈话》之前的剧集。你也可以访问我们的网站，收听所有剧集：www.speakingofpsychology.org。如果你有关于未来播客的评论或想法，请发送电子邮件至speakingofpsychology@apa.org。感谢收听，我是美国心理学会的
Association. I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
金·米尔斯。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。